the first thing I started thinking about
that is and maybe I'm wrong but it seems
like this only has upside I don't just
mean the financial I mean the lack of
you know of using animals to provide
this this meat of the impact on the
environment the impact really may be
ethically and and certainly now
highlighted
more than ever and I want to hear your
take on this bike Ovid which has really
been traced and enlarged in some part I
should say to these slaughterhouses and
the outbreaks in there so first I'm
rambling a little bit but I'd like to
know does this have any downsides except
for you know people might lose money and
that's just the nature of our capitalist
economy but it's her downside to it and
your opinion you know I think that this
really hits on like a fascinating
element of something that I figured out
as I started really digging into this
space is that there is a divide when you
talk to the entrepreneurs and the
innovators who are behind this is that
when you talk to them about sell
cultured meet some of them referred to
it as technology and some of them refer
to it as food and I think that one of
the things that sort of really separates
this from like an Instagram or social
media and Silicon Valley is that food is
an incredibly emotional incredibly
political incredibly personal thing that
we interact with every every single
person no matter how much money you have
you know that could like sort of change
what kinds of foods you can eat but we
all eat the same way it goes through the
same goes through the same orifice in
our where billion year old hardware and
and for that reason I think that you're
gonna find some people saying like oh
there is a downside I think that you
would talk to not very far out of
Silicon Valley herself Alice Waters who
would say that we're getting way too far
from nature and that in doing this you
sort of think that you sort of you know
we're almost challenging nature in some
way that like we can do better
hmm and I think for people who come from
that person
active I think that this is a downside
that this is sort of the granddaddy of
processed foods in in some way and we've
seen what processed foods not a fair
comparison but like you know pop-tarts
haven't really done that much for the
for our health and it's also a super
processed food so I think that you can
really start diving into lots of
conversations around what this means in
like an emotional level or unless with a
natural level that like poses lots of
big questions about whether this has a
downside or not but to the things that
you brought up the impact on climate
change the how this could really mean
kovat 19 is an excellent example I think
that in fact I think Ovid 19 is sort of
a horrible gift that now this these this
sort of nascent industry has if you
think about before this virus and then
this pandemic sort of set in when you
read about cell cultures meat if you
read about it you probably mostly heard
two things it's it's gonna be so much
much better when it comes to like sort
of the effort to combat climate change
and it's going to result in killing a
lot fewer animals and those are huge
upsides what COBIT 19 has done is it has
exposed at least especially in the u.s.
that the u.s. meat system is fraught
with problems I mean think about it has
exposed to us the more about the labor
conditions inside the meatpacking plants
and how tightly packed everything still
is because we don't use robots to tear
apart carcasses that come down the
assembly line because they're all
different shapes and sizes
we still need humans to do this and
their shoulders are shoulder doing the
nitty-gritty hard work of packaging of
ripping apart and packaging our meat for
us and I think that this has unveiled
for us or in a very real way that maybe
you aren't that far off from where we
were in the jungle when upton sinclair
wrote his famous book i think that it
sort of shows the weakness of having
this hyper consolidated meats
system where a very tiny handful of
companies and a very tiny handful of
factories are responsible for putting
out 85 percent of our meat that way if
you have a nine meatpacking plant shut
down suddenly 25 percent of the meat
supply is impacted mmm and so suddenly I
think that you can these industry groups
can our sorry these these sort of sell
cultured meat startups are suddenly
going to be able to seize on all of
these very real downsides in the current
meat system which have resulted in
higher meat prices which have resulted
in CEOs with Smithfield and Tyson saying
oh my gosh like we all better prepare
this could be bad for our meat supply
there could be shortages and I think
that um you know in addition to all the
climate climate related upsides you know
we're now seeing some new upsides yeah
so one of our guests recently Peter
Diamandis who is known for he's I call
him the most optimistic pessimist or the
most pessimistic optimist but he talks
about these six exponential DS are the
six DS of the exponential growth and one
of those is as disruptive and and and
this applied when I have a conversation
with Sarah fryer about Instagram or book
no filter and that's how you know
companies like Kodak and and other
companies really didn't see this coming
and I wonder you know for these Tyson's
and these other companies besides
obviously they're gonna lobby and
they're gonna try to stay in trench do
you see opportunities for these
companies that are actually the
traditional you know far far more you
know kind of slaughterhouse and cetera
meat packaging industries of today to
benefit or are they just gonna do what
Kodak did and then lose this this
overall battle for you know what could
be doing well while doing good yeah I
think that's a really interesting
question and I think that you know I
spend a decent amount of time in the
book I think looking back at some of the
food fights in America and you just you
know for listeners you know one of the
early houd flights that actually led to
the creation of the dairy Lobby was the
the butter the
people being so threatened by the
arrival of margarine that they just went
bonkers and state state houses across
this country and including and in
Washington you try to get legislation
passed that would basically you know
legislate margin out of existence I
think that we see it today whenever we
see the dairy industry again like
feeling so threatened by plant-based
milks that they are like doing
everything they can and they failed so
far in the Jews and the judiciary but
they're doing everything they can now is
the legislative branch to like basically
make it so that you can't call almond
milk milk because consumers are just
going to be so confused and I think that
the meat people have learned some of
them at least a little bit from that and
I think that's evident from high-profile
appearances that CEOs of big meat
companies have made where they've used
language that kind of shows it I think
it was Tom Hayes with is the former CEO
of Tyson appeared on like Fox Business a
year and a year year and a half ago and
he started using language where he
basically specifically said like oh
we're not a meat company anymore we're a
protein company because they see that
there is interest in plant-based protein
they see that there could be interest in
cell culture protein they see that there
is still interest in animal-based
protein and the fact that these big
companies that have always identified as
meat companies are now calling
themselves protein companies signals to
me that they see
omma like the writing on the wall that
there are future foods out there that
people are very curious about them and
eager to try them and I think that sell
cultured meat is one of those foods and
will be one of those foods